non mi riconosci
l'italia si legge non rino avete
presente la creatura che stavo cercando
dal piano di sopra
sì c'è un problema che problema
l'ho trovata ma mi ha morso il lupo
proprio e il lupo che cosa succederà
adesso no no non ci siamo non ci siamo
non va beh quindi che cosa posso fare
adesso se vuoi sapere cosa succederà a
per il libro e il reggino ciascuna
creatura si trasformerà il lupo mannaro
che ora cosa facciamo o scappiamo anche
perché diventa pericolosa ma ci deve
essere una soluzione no tu che stiamo
non lo saprai qual è la soluzione sono
un modo per fermarla questa
trasformazione
credo che se un po tardi adesso l'unico
modo è catturare la creatura che chi ha
fatto questo sono scappata ma non ho
fatto in tempo a catturarla e ora cosa
faccio non voglio trasformarmi ormai è
troppo tardi ti dobbiamo rinchiudere
vitale dobbiamo rinchiuderla ricchi a
debito
qui qui e noi andiamo via se passerà
questa notte domani non ci sarà più un
problema ma stanotte tu sei
pericolosissima sarei b era di pelè
avrai le foci così no non va bene
dobbiamo scappare lui vitali dobbiamo
scappare andiamo e vero rita io credo
che abbia ragione potresti essere molto
pericolosa potresti potreste addirittura
mangiarvi quindi forse è meglio se ci
chiudiamo qui resti tranquilla
tranquilla solo per questa notte poi da
domani già sarà tutto diverso
va bene
domani ma mirati vento da bere ma sono
sempre troppo marmo per non farmi
trasformare lui un lupo saprà come si
fanno e come detto il sistema buona
salute c'è pure una scheda che matura e
domani mattina hanno attinto molto
trasformarmi io voglio anche da quello
nord io poi mi sento benissimo mondo e
credo che mi trasformerò da in qualche
paese che scrivo delle lettere tele
passò sotto la porta così a giocare
magari
un'altra soluzione roma un'altra
lezione che l'us army palazzo tu che ne
pensi
non c'è un'altra soluzione no no no no
stai un altro aspetto così quello
sono un po preoccupato dal m xvi che
domani si sentirà meglio forse dovrei
stare tranquillo tema sicuro tutto anni
e sarà abbassato tutto speriamo di non
essere intenzioni
io so all'inter lo so che non servì come
una romana facciamo passare solo questa
notte
ma io non mi grazie al menu comandarono
un misterioso che può mandarmi 0
eppure io mi sento benissimo
anzi non credo proprio che mi
trasformerò e mi sento diversa questa
volta forse con la creatura non era un
lupo magari a qualcos'altro magari era
solo un cane e quindi non mi trasformerò
il lupo mannaro
devo dirglielo subito vabbè lasciamo
perdere hanno troppa paura anche l'ex ha
paura eppure lui e mezzo gruppo mezzo
umano non dovrebbe avere paura di un
lupo mannaro no a dire ti aspetterò qua
aspettiamo questa trasformazione che
secondo me non succederà e secondo voi
se non avete ancora lasciato un mi piace
mi raccomando e lasciate un mi piace qui
sotto che cosa potrei fare nel frattempo
ha ovviamente leggiamo il mio libro
e voi ce l'avete è disponibile in tutte
le librerie e su amazon non riuscirete a
smettere di leggerlo storie paurose con
due ragazzini e due ragazzine come
protagonisti compagni di classe amici
per la pelle a un certo punto però
arriva una nuova insegnante una
supplente che è un po paurosa un po
particolare e assegna loro il compito di
fare delle ricerche su alcune creature
tra cui
lupi mannari e vampiri e poi non vi
spoiler o altro con ogni storia che
finirete di leggere accumulerete dei
punti il coraggio e alla fine del libro
e base a quanti punti avete accumulato
potrete scoprire a quale profilo
porterete è bellissimo anche se non vi
piace leggere o non vi piace tante
leggere o vi annoia questo libro non vi
annoierà per niente anzi vi terrà col
fiato sospeso fino alla fine quindi se
non se lo avete ancora andati a
prenderle nel frattempo che aspetto
leggo un po
adesso come ti dicevo si trasformerà in
un lupo mannaro e succederà esattamente
quando il primo raggio di luna l'ha
colpito quindi manca poco e già buio
pesto là fuori e penny ladies in
questione di attimi anzi senti senti
ecco selex vieni avvicinati anche tu
sentire io non ho bisogno io ci sento
benissimo guarda che orecchie che optano
un 2 m effettivamente sì e non fa una
piega
[Musica]
l'ex una cosa mostruosa questa sì sto
trasformando
abbiamo fatto bene e chiudono in camera
mi avrebbe sbranato fermato
completamente sarebbe diventata così
alta che avrebbe fatto in 123 bocconi
forse al massimo quindi adesso
aspettiamo fino a domani mattina
esattamente dove mattina vita tornerà
normale speriamo bene ma non sento più i
rumori in effetti anche io con il mio
super udito non sento più niente che
cosa sarà successo
qui c'è davvero qualcosa di strano
andare a controllare non farlo in
parlamento fanno fa guarda che è
intelligente lupo mannaro forse questa è
una trappola sai che ti potrebbe sperare
però io mi sto preoccupando per anita ma
non lo so why inciampato si è fatta del
male svenuta devono controllare puoi
andare al premio ti prego ci metterà in
pericolo io lo so finire malissimo
finiva mai tu sei un lupo leggere ma che
non solo controllare se tu applico la
porta io sono il primo a scappare ok va
bene allora troviamo compromesso uscivo
solo io andrò a controllare e tu
rimarrai qui al sicuro con la porta
chiusa che così si sbrana sbrana solo me
è troppo pericoloso lo dico per te
credimi non ti preoccupare so ballare in
me stessa e soprattutto una scolarità
questa però che non è anita non è una
meta che conosci tu e così alta è piena
di benuzzi
meloni a vita e famelica capisci è un
pericolo e va bene sono pronto da super
me questo pericolo ci penserò io tu non
ti preoccupare rimani qui
me ne occupo io ma sono sicuro che la
vita non mi farà del male se tranquillo
grazie comunque per i consigli io me ne
vado vado a controllare
ci vediamo fra poco bene volevo dire che
non ci aveva avvisato tu rimani come
berlino
lì da anita tutto bene sul tetto non c'è
nemmeno sul lampadario magari a sotto al
letto
anita dove sei magari qua sopra anita
ha lasciato il libro qua a limita si è
trasformata il lupo mannaro ha lasciato
il libero e non c'è più
[Musica]
o no e scappato dalla finestra qualità
questo è un disastro parità trasformato
il lupo mannaro e là fuori è
pericolosissima non posso lasciarla
libera così da sola possono non avere
qualcuno può trovare qualcuno deve
uscire subito alla devo cercare la devo
trovare e soprattutto la devo fermare
non posso permettere che morda qualcun
altro che trasformi qualcun altro in un
lupo mannaro
portato il libro così almeno mi guiderà
da anita
sta funzionando
godiamoci lo spettacolo
[Risate]
sanità unito dove sei sono venuto a
salva partito
marito la
tradisse nascosta allora il punto della
situazione in questo momento è questo
lui crede veramente di non trovarla ma
lei l'ha già visto lasciato intatto non
andrà a finire tanto bene
l'ho trovata
eccola lì
aveva ragione l'ex è diventata gigante e
anche pelosissimo
unità sono io non mi riconosci
aspettando campo
bellissimo non sapevo ci volevano i pop
corn ci voleva poco chiare
[Musica]
che carini
adoro queste scene romantiche
adesso però è vero sai io ti ha
privatizzato e visto cosa è successo se
la si è vista proprio brutta
io mi sono divertito
stavo per prendermi e una a mordere sito
visto io ho visto tutto ho visto tutto
da qui scene romantiche come tu sei
stato veramente veramente bravo non c'è
cosa stai dicendo ho rischiato
tantissimo
sì mi darete l'avevo detto ma è mai
chiuso la porta a chiave
la chiave non hai chiuso la porta a
chiave
il problema
non è che non ho chiuso la porta a
chiave non ho chiuso la porta non è
chiusa neanche la porta ma cosa ti dice
cervello e stavo scappando di fretta è
un tubo mannaro è un lupo mannaro non è
anita è un lupo mannaro e ci mangia e se
vado a chiuderla adesso non lo so adesso
proviamo proviamo magani già dentro
dobbiamo volare dal detto dobbiamo
volare capisci dobbiamo scappare
dobbiamo scappare si svolgerà massimo e
mi ricordo se l'ho chiusa la porta ma
credo di no per i romani
almeno chiediamo questa porta magari non
arriva qui
moriremo tutti non c'è la chiave
siamo salvi borse
[Musica]